I wanted to talk about this yesterday
but didn't have time last week after
weeks and weeks of not taking questions
in a press conference after days of
having nothing public on his calendar
whatsoever Trump decided to do basically
a campaign rally he went to Ohio to do a
rally in front of a friendly crowd kind
of like what you do when you're running
for president supposedly it was going to
be an infrastructure speech by the way
how often is it infrastructure week it
seems like almost every week in this
administration is infrastructure week
Trump went completely and totally off
the rails it turned into a very strange
garbled rant resembling the English
language only loosely and demonstrating
a sort of Sarah Palin like inability to
communicate anything of meaning through
language and it got so bad that the
three major cable networks CNN MSNBC and
Fox News all just cut away from the
speech although you'll be pleased to
know that good old Fox Business Network
stayed with the entire thing all the way
through here is Fox bailing when it got
weird former george w bush white house
press secretary dana perino who's now a
fox news anchor fittingly explaining
that they are going away and she looked
sort of in physical pain as she said it
32,000 soldiers are even watching
president Russell is in Ohio giving a
speech wide-ranging speech but mostly
focusing on his infrastructure plan and
former White House deputy chief of staff
Karl Rove is back with me I like that
wide-ranging is code for Trump is all
over the place real quick go to Karl
Rove to try to say this save us here so
even Fox cutting away even though they
did stay with it a few minutes longer
than CNN Emmett and MSNBC so here just
random weird moments the entire speech
was totally off the rails all right
here's just a random 20 seconds of Trump
from the speech
we're very important and respected in
some circles Democrat said we want to
get rid we should get rid of our Second
Amendment in other words get rid of it
that's really good
could be right about that so we're going
to protect our Second Amendment that's
not going to happen we have the best
judges we put on a tremendous amount of
great Federal District Court judges will
be setting records we are setting
records appeals court judges Supreme
Court judge fantastic justice Gorsuch
what is he talking about setting records
like what what the hell is this guy on
just another few seconds from Trump's
bizarre speech that networks couldn't
even stay with and we didn't have one
Democrat who voted they want to raise
your taxes and they want people to come
in from the border and they want I guess
want I can't imagine they want but
certainly drugs are flowing across
borders we need walls we started
building our wall I'm so proud of it I
started we started we have 1.6 billion
and we've already started you saw the
pictures yesterday I said what a thing
of beauty and on September 28th we go
further yeah that was a lie by the way
the pictures he's referring to were from
the replacement of 2 miles of border
fence dating back to the 1990s we've got
one more clip again just disjointed
rantings of a madman we spent and I was
against it from the beginning they try
and say well maybe not I was against it
from the beginning and by the way we're
knocking the hell out of Isis will be
coming out of Syria like very soon let
the other people take care of it now
very soon very soon we're coming out
we're gonna have a hundred percent of
the Caliphate as they call it sometimes
referred to as land go back quickly
quickly but we're gonna be coming out of
there real soon gonna get back to our
country where we belong where we want to
be but just think of it we spent as of
three months ago seven trillion dollars
not billion not million seven trillion
with a t nobody ever heard of the word
trillion until 10 years ago
we spent seven trillion dollars in the
Middle East we'd build a school that
blow it up we'd build it again they'd
blow it up we'd build it again
has it been blown up yet but it will be
but if we want a school in Ohio to fix
the windows you can't get the money if
you want a school in Pennsylvania or
Iowa to get federal money you can't get
the money we spent seven trillion
dollars in the Middle East and you know
we have for it nothing remember I used
to say keep the oil as a civilian
I used to say did anybody hear me say
that that's before I decided to go in
this journey with all of you I got tired
of watching what on earth is this guy
talking about i it is the disjointed
rantings of someone who understands
nothing it's always infrastructure week
or month or whatever nothing actually
happens except Trump just showing up and
talking about his random random musings
here and it's there's two phases of a
Trump speech there's the horrible syntax
of the teleprompter reading where he's
looking off at an angle and saying and
if we were to become a better nation of
and then we would write like it's just
you can't read it it just makes no sense
whatsoever and then you see when he
shifts off the teleprompter and look
straight ahead and but then you don't
even know what the guy's talking about
because he's just completely off the
rails and improvising and I hope that
soon we actually get a press conference
supposedly he's doing one today
questions like mr. president can you
just say definitively did you have sex
with stormy Daniels did you realize that
your people were knowingly and directly
dealing with Russian intelligence
officers did you know about the hundred
and thirty thousand dollars that Michael
Cohen paid stormy Daniels have you
reimbursed some specific questions and
you you can't put him out there because
he could end up saying something
horribly self incriminating so I hope we
get a press conference soon these
speeches are but so bizarre that even
Fox News had to cut away from it even if
he did get those questions though I
think he would go off on a tangent about
how he won the 2016 election it was
greatest victory of all time
baby got to deflect maybe he would but I
think he would very likely end up saying
something totally totally self
incriminating and it's pretty clear
they're trying to keep him away from
those types of questions hopefully he
will get some today bizarre speech that
a lot of people on our subreddit noticed
and you can join that discussion if you
can stomach it at david pakman.com slash
our EDD IT today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
brilliant you watch the David Pakman
show
or listen to the David Pakman show so
clearly you're interested in politics
and in following what's going on in the
world and the economy the environment
but what's crucial to understand is that
almost everything we talk about on this
show is sort of on the foundation of
math science and philosophy and keeping
up with the news is one thing but you're
never really fully equipped to
understand political issues and have
debates with people until you've
actually developed a more complete
understanding of how the world works and
how these issues work at the most
fundamental level and brilliant is one
of the most effective and enjoyable ways
to do that that I've ever come across
you can learn hands-on about statistics
crime climate science energy it's a long
list and you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman first two hundred
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will also get 20% off an
annual premium and membership check it
out sign up for free today at brilliant
org slash David Pakman